hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to see him now this is a
speedrunning game it's just the demo of
it but it's a speedrunning first-person
perspective game and what that means is
you're running through the depths of
hell
probably away from your problems in your
family and you're trying to get by
trying to make the highest score you
possibly can so you can get on the
diabolical leaderboards and then go home
maybe just like that but it gets much
more complicated this may just be the
demo and it's the only one that I played
before but it's probably [ __ ] I died how
do I die in hell that doesn't make a lot
of sense but I'm gonna try my best I'm
if yeah ah hell yeah I think I did it I
don't know what a whoa I'm number 23 I'm
leaderboard that's kind of good okay SAS
so there's gonna be a few levels here
and I don't I don't know exactly what
I'm supposed to be home
I just smashed headfirst into some
spikes
ah [ __ ] alright huh boink all right
there we go
kabuki hot risky where am I going
oh [ __ ] yeah hoodude I did okay I want
to try that again and it's got to be
something else there's like things that
you can yeah ah [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah ha ha
Wow boom okay so oh [ __ ]
yeah I did much better that time I'm
gonna get the high score all over this
yeah that's a trick oh god it was not as
Wow okay I'm gonna be taking my time
with this one whoever back oh god damn
it I didn't mean to do that
that was Miss Tia kept well ah [ __ ]
what hey answer I don't know why
ah [ __ ] apparently I'm bad at this who
would have thought Burt Burt now I don't
know why this guy is kind of like a
trucker in the
the hell and I took the long way around
holy [ __ ] what did I do
there must be another way ah that's the
stuff okay I get it
huh I'm asking ya alright let me try
that again
yeah oh yeah oh yeah okay so I did that
I'm number 55 I did better the last time
fine whatever oh [ __ ]
alright prison escape I don't know how
to do this huh [ __ ] yeah ah [ __ ] whoa
it's a secret
Oh teleport ball Wow beer I have to get
to my beer or so what I said I'm not on
a percent sure about that one but let me
try that again
yeah [ __ ] I don't think this is right
now that I know how to use it whoa yeah
Wow number four hell yeah I can do that
again I can do a little better yep [ __ ]
Wow yeah
first place yeah okay that may not seem
like a lot to you but any accomplishment
is amazing for me all right now it's
probably gonna start to get more
complicated because we're gonna have a
whole bunch of [ __ ] Oh God
ah jeez I wasn't ready yeah [ __ ] OOP
[ __ ]
ah shitty tits up nah this is the worst
of the worst 99 plus yeah I know why cuz
I'm terrible [ __ ] I got the power but
not the ability to do well in Lao whoa
what the [ __ ] was that
well I think I learned a new trick oh I
forgot oh that's gonna be useful okay
here we go
hep hep hep hep oh [ __ ] oh oh okay
that's gonna be a thing
Oh way cuerpo okay
Oh wasn't ready Oh God oh [ __ ] I almost
had that that would have been legendary
huh pip chip but tip math [ __ ] whoa
number 18 that did better I don't know
if I'll be able to do better on that one
I'll try the next one
whoo this looks fun it's just a bunch of
sores are they going to slice my
buttocks
well can't get me can't get me can't get
me oh they got me
don't laugh at me you wouldn't laugh at
a guy with glasses would you pop oh [ __ ]
scary what so far so goo ah whoa okay
boink well hell yeah let's try that
again
I want to at least get on the
leaderboard that'd be nice swell ow my
taint
right on the blades [ __ ] attack fake
attack raccattack racc attack
oh come on ow
ow ow
I thought maybe it was one of those
things where you could just run straight
into it but apparently not I'm 42 I'll
take it it's at least it's the answer to
all the questions in the universe but
are you first gravity that doesn't seem
like whoop well [ __ ] I don't know how it
is ah
I need to watch the movie again perfect
yeah oh man that was terrible
let's try that again ha ha ha ha still
bad Hey
Hey all right we go we go we go no no no
no no no no no I don't know well well
well well well good thing hell painted
these convenient signs I went you huh hi
I'm asking by Blink yeah way not even
close to the leaderboard I'm gonna skip
that one come up on the final level holy
[ __ ] charge okay what am I looking for
ah okay oh jeez
that's not good oh [ __ ]
all right so I got to do a thing oh boy
ow
no up hep hep oh god that's that's like
off sync ah it's not quite every pub
[ __ ] here shut up about the stupid
barbecue I love [ __ ] who's gonna be
difficult commercial come asking a [ __ ]
oh you can do short jump so okay I don't
know why I wasn't able to do those
before hip hip hip hip hip okay we're
going up we're going up we're going up
let's I don't know what that dad but
sounds good yeah okay up up up up shove
ascii lang good
all right under my butt hey [ __ ] you
back i read at the end there
that's not cool bruh hey hey hey okay up
up up up up Fabo skate get it get it get
it nail a nail a nail
ah [ __ ] off with this [ __ ] a bunch
of bo2 [ __ ] fire on your dick why okay
trap
oh come on [ __ ] you
okay let's see okay here we go whoa baby
number 18 I'll take it I'm not doing
that one again so that was I believe the
last of the demo and I need pretty okay
I got number one on one of those levels
anyway which is more than I can say for
most of the games that I play now this
may be just a demo but this has a lot of
potential I mean the demo is free so you
can play it right now and try to beat my
high score if you want I'll pull link
down in the description maybe I'll play
when the full game comes out so thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
a ballad that wasn't even there before